الان ينضم الينا من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
في دير البلح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت
هشام الغارات مستمره في مناطق مختلفه في
القطاع طلعنا على اخر التطورات
لديك وسيله اخر التطورات هي صعبه الوصول
اليها بسبب انقطاع الانترنت انقطاع
الاتصالات بشكل كامل عن قطاع غزه وبالتالي
نقص وشح المعلومه حتى شح المعلومه ل
صحفيين وحتى لسيارات الاسعاف وطواقم
الدفاع المدني التي كانت تتلقى اتصالات من
المواطنين ليبلغوه عن طبيعه الاستهدافات
الاسرائيليه اين يتواجد الشهداء واين يمكن
اجلاء المصابين وبالتالي الان انقطع
الاتصال بشكل كامل مع هذه الطواقم سواء
الاسعاف او حتى طواقم الدفاع المدني
بالتالي انقطاع الاتصالات وانقطاع
الانترنت يعزل قطاع غزه بشكل كامل عن
العالم ويعزل حتى سكان القطاع عن هذه
الطواقم بشكل كبير لكن ما استطعنا رصده
خلال الساعه الماضيه على الاقل وبالتاكيد
من ساعات الصباح ونحن نتابع هذه الاحداث
في مدينه غزه في منطقه الصفطاوي نقل سته
شهداء الى مستشفى الشفاء من جراء عمليات
قنص ينفذها الجيش الاسرائيلي في تلك
المنطقه على ما يبدو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعتلى بعض الابنيه في تلك المنطقه ويطلق
النار على كل ما يتحرك في منطقه الصفطاوي
من المعروف ان حي الشيخ رضوان ومنطقه
الصفطاوي تشهد ايضا عمليات اطلاق نار
وعمليات توغل من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي تنسحب من منطقه وتتمركز
وتعيد التمركز والتموضع في منطقه اخرى
وبالتالي يعتقد السكان بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي انسحب من هذه المنطقه فيحاول
الخروج بعدما كانوا محاصرين لعده ايام
فيطلق عليهم الجيش الاسرائيلي النار فقتل
حتى الان سته وهذا ما عرف وما استطاع
السكان حتى الان نقله الى مستشفى الشفاء
لكن هناك بكل تاكيد المزيد من الشهداء لم
تستطع لا طواقم الاسعاف ولا حتى السكان
العاديين نقلهم الى المستشفى هذا ما يحدث
في غزه لا سيما في الجهه الغربيه لكن في
الجهه الشرقيه لمدينه غزه احياء الدرج
احياء الشجاعيه احياء حي التفاح تشهد ايضا
قصفا مدفعيه من قبل الطائرات من قبل
المدفعيه والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
وايضا من الطائ ارات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
التي تنفذ ما بين الفينه والاخرى غارات لم
تعرف بالضبط ماذا تستهدف لكن جل الغارات
ومنذ بدايه هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه تستهدف
المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه تدمرها
وتسويها بالارض على رؤوس السكان كما حدث
في المنطقه الوسطى التي باتت تشهد قصفا
عنيفا من المدفعيه من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه منذ يومين تكثف الطائرات
والمدفعيه قصفها لمخيمات المنطقه الوسطى
لا سما شمال مخيم النصيرات مخيم النصيرات
شهد بالامس وفجر هذا اليوم غارات عنيفه
استهدفت منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه منزل لعائله
نصار في المخيم الجديد في مخيم النصيرات
ايضا منزل لعائله الحزقي في مخيم النصيرات
بجانب مسجد القسام وبكل تاكيد هناك شهداء
وجرحى من جراء هذه الغارات التي استهدفت
هذه المنازل ايضا مخيم المغازي شهد كذلك
قصفا اسرائيليا ونقل من مدرسه الاواء خمسه
شهداء من جراء قصف مدفعي اسرائيل اشكرك
جزيل الشكر هشام زقوت مراسلنا من دير
البلح